la escalada de muertes este año tiene
que ver con la llegada al poder de la
derecha más extrema o sigue la línea de
los anteriores gobiernos
Bueno yo creo que sigue la línea de
gobiernos anteriores Naciones Unidas por
ejemplo nos alertó que el año 2022 fue
uno de los más mortales para los
palestinos desde el dos y recordemos que
antes estaba el gobierno de yahirle con
lo cual esto comprueba de alguna manera
es una consecuencia o una agenda
permanente en los gobiernos de Israel
qué supone ahora la declaración de las
autoridades palestinas del fin inmediato
de la coordinación de seguridad con
Israel
Bueno yo creo que en primer lugar esto
Nunca debió haber pasado es decir firmar
los acuerdos de cooperación de seguridad
en qué sentido en que desde la
perspectiva de la autoridad Palestina
firmar un acuerdo donde implica
básicamente dos cosas
de detener palestinos haciéndole el
trabajo a Israel en territorio de
cisjordania y también dar información de
los palestinos de tus propios ciudadanos
a Israel es la potencia ocupante o tu
enemigo entre comillas Pues yo creo que
era una profunda contradicción ahora
Esto no es la primera vez que sucede ya
había pasado antes ya sea amenazar de
suspender o suspender efectivamente Los
acuerdos pero es algo que yo creo se va
a resumir en los próximos días
y aparte de esto una política del nuevo
gobierno es acelerar la creación de
asentamientos podría esto causar la
radicalización de parte de la población
Palestina y por tanto una nueva escalada
de violencia
yo creo que sí recordémosle a la
audiencia que una organización israelí
de judíos sacó un informe donde nos dijo
que entre el año de 1967 al año 2017 se
crearon o construyeron más de 26
asentamientos en cisjordania y que Eso
provoca que haya cerca de seiscientos
veinte mil colonos israelíes viviendo en
Jordania cuando uno Observa que hay por
ejemplo protestas en habs Precisamente
en contra de la presencia de colonos que
siempre tienen el instrumento de la
violencia como primera herramienta y
obviamente conflictos en la ciudad de
yening yo creo que esto nos ayuda a
entender mucho por ejemplo muchas
personas se preguntan porque un
palestino puede recurrir a la violencia
un grupo armado Aquí está una de las
razones Mientras más haya asentamientos
y colonos violentos no nos preguntemos
porque un palestino puede optar por la
resistencia o unirse a un grupo armado
una cosa lleva lo otro
y brevemente le quería hacer una última
pregunta hemos visto recientemente
protestas dentro de Israel por cómo se
trata Está tratando precisamente
el tema con Palestina estas protestas
podrían llevar quizás a algo mayor a que
se retirara esta política contra el
pueblo palestino o simplemente quizás
sea una atenuación del conflicto
bueno las protestas en Israel
básicamente son en contra del gobierno
de ultraderecha que uno bien Podría
calificar Sin temor a equivocarse con
elementos racistas y fascistas son los
mismos israelíes los que han salido en
las calles tanto antes de la llegada de
yahirla Pit en contra de bengamine and
Yahoo Cómo contra el regreso de Benjamín
como Primer Ministro y tu gobierno de
ultraderecha Yo veo que la agenda
Palestina no hace parte de este
movimiento de protesta israelí sin que
ellos no signifique que hay sectores
dentro de Israel donde haya una
solidaridad por el pueblo palestino y
que llamen a un acuerdo fuera o lejos de
la violencia